[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want we got tesh
here tash is somewhat of a weed expert
actually oh we might know him on tv
shows and such as such but we just
realized that he is a
weed scientist
i've invested in a couple of uh uh
cannabis companies how did you get into
it one of my friends uh
he
you know always used to talk about it he
was using it as medicine you know he it
wasn't because you guys like to party no
never never never he seems like a very
responsible guy why would we even think
that right look everything in excess is
bad for you it's very true and that
doesn't could be anything you know so
you gotta you gotta keep it balanced a
balanced lifestyle but i do think
cannabis is being used more as a
medicine and rightfully so there's
there's a research to help back that up
and
you know if you can uh wean off the
alcohol you know
and maybe opioids and stuff like that
might be a better decision for some
people
you don't like it don't do it that's
true if you like it go for it fat ass
hit a weed and get my balls licked
it feels good huh hell yeah it's dope
that's a good advertisement for a weed
sounds like a fun time one big hit and a
one big hit
billboard a billboard of a guy
he's just holding his dick and there's
someone licking it and there's just a
weed plant right there
that guy smokes pie yeah i think that's
what happened to uh nicki minaj's like
cousin's husband's friend did you guys
see that what happened with that the
whole tweet she said like her cousin's
friend got her swollen balls because
from the vaccine but they were i think
they were from
i don't know yeah it's probably an std
just by base on the description but yeah
he could have been smoking weed who
knows
he could have been doing the rubber band
method to his testicles yeah because
that gets swollen really good yeah
that's great what's that method so you
were talking to your buddies about it um
while you weren't getting your balls lit
no exactly and then and so there you you
what made you go i should invest it
cannabis went legal i saw that the the
benefits that it has you know i've been
following the nfl closely and all these
guys suffering from ct you mean
recreationally legal or medical both
it's both in california it's now
recreationally legal so but medically it
went yeah so medically it goes legal the
first thing it goes is like oh okay
pharmaceutical companies think they can
make money off of this so pharmaceutical
companies can make money off of it it's
obviously the public eventually will be
able to make money off of it and
they can you know obviously influence
super pacs and it's going to change and
if you look at the trend now nationally
it's going in that direction and it's so
positive now and during kovid a lot of
states are going to use it to generate
tax revenue
you know in california gets taxed at
every single stage from seed to sale
as they say in the business so it's just
an avenue and i always say yo if you're
going to sell cannabis sell a cannabis
and put all the money back into
infrastructure put into schools put it
into town development didn't colorado
like crush it with their taxes so in
colorado i believe sales of cannabis now
outsell alcohol wow
but it also helped the state i heard of
course because they're using the money
to develop whatever they need to develop
what's big alcohol going to do now
invest in cannabis
same way cigarette companies are going
to invest in cannabis like
heineken right is big billion dollar
company lagunitas came out of northern
california can't compete with that craft
beer market they buy them
right chillette comes in dollar shave
club comes in can't compete with their
market let's just buy them so that's
kind of like the move for a lot of
cannabis maybe maybe so we'll see you
know i think it's very it's very kind of
early on there's a lot of growing pains
people are
starting to jump into the business from
sort of the more professional sector and
a lot of these ogs are kind of bouncing
back
from that because they've been in the
shadows their whole lives so i think
there's a balance and it'll get there
but i think it's something it's a new
and exciting market to be in you know if
i told everyone at this table should we
invest in vodka or tequila 100 years ago
but you know people used to say
during during the uh prohibition
movement or the suffrage movement women
used to protest and say we need to
league out as cannabis because our
husbands don't beat us on weed
when they're high but they get
aggressive when they're drunk
that's true i never heard of a wife
beating pot smoker doesn't happen just
the lazy one though it's like it's
either they don't pay the bills but they
still don't pay the bills on alcohol
anyway and they beat their wives
the history of cannabis is so like is so
linked to
the racial history of this country and
business and obviously
connecting it with you know
people of color at that time you know i
thought it was because they they wanted
to incarcerate uh yeah the black
population because they were the ones
actually smoking and not not everyone in
a mexican right yeah but if you look at
stats now it's the usage is the same but
if you look at the way that they're
probably prosecuted or arrested it's
probably very imbalanced between the two
different communities and like
on top of it i think when nixon the
whole thing about why cannabis is bad is
because it comes you know you have hemp
which is like one of the derivatives and
hemp can be a really strong fabric or
you know cash product and it's a
competitor to cotton which was a cash
in the cotton lobby actually for the
united states right yeah yeah and so
they just they crush it but like that's
why if you go to like you know asian
countries or like especially in india
like everything's made out of [ __ ]
hemp hemp rope bags tempted attempt that
right the trendy stuff yeah it's all
politics and money man it was like
i think that's when i was like dude all
this [ __ ] is just money because it's not
a moral ethical issue no if it was
people they would address the opioid
crisis they wouldn't be people wouldn't
be addicted to vicodin you know you have
these football players or you know these
major athletes who are injuring
themselves fighters stuff like that they
get addicted to painkillers and it's
like okay look try not to be addicted to
anything but if you had to choose
between taking vicodin every day 10
times a day or smoking a joint to
relieve your pain which one would you
rather take yeah
they're hurting now big time yeah you
you mentioned something about cte and
like marijuana use what was the well i
think i think there's there's been a lot
of you know
i'm not an expert in this medically but
i think there's been success with
former nfl players using cannabis to
believe their issues and treat their
ailments and they just approved it right
the nfl allowed that i don't know that i
don't know i know they were they were
protesting to put cannabis on the list i
know they removed it for baseball
yeah no the nba too right i don't know
if they were they just not testing
people in the new uh cba that they just
did they allow for
marijuana use as long as it's medical
okay but um but yeah it's it's to combat
cte mostly yeah because you you're
having a lot of players who probably for
them and i don't know what's going on
with the nfl they're
commit killing themselves yeah and i
don't know what kind of
payout that they have to pay anybody
needs it as a nfl player yeah and it's
just like
why would you want that because then for
them it's like you're injuring the
longevity of their careers and that's
from their standpoint is a business
right and so if they have a product that
only has a shelf life of two years if
they can be like oh they can safely do
this for five years and they can feel
safe and they make money it's business
for everybody everybody wins everybody
wins is daniel jones the answer in new
york
[Laughter]
no no who is this guy he's a quarterback
quarterback
danny dimes he's he's a giants fan i'm a
giants fan yeah i'm giant snakes i don't
know too much about football that's all
i was like are you naming crap yeah one
guy who would actually answer a football
question a question about football now
we can move on
no i don't think he's the answer why do
you think everyone focuses on thc number
like every time i go to dispensary
they're like man this one this one's
like [ __ ] 20 something i'm just like
they don't know better i'm like i don't
let me let me let me ask you this this
and this is what i always say give me
the light you need you need the balance
between thc and cbd and the total number
uh but
it's it it would be the equivalent of
someone going to a bar and being like yo
give me the shot of 151. wow i only want
151 all the time gross
exactly gross that's what i mean
when i but when i walk into it and they
give me the biggest one i'm like bro i'm
lightweight give me the lowest one
the lower than low but 151 so cool when
there's another one
on fire so you know you can set it on
fire you can set your weed on i kind of
miss the days
of the weed where i can like i'm like
still on this planet try it
am i am i allowed to do a shout out yeah
yeah do a shout out atrium cultivation
check it out pick it up at expenses
we're in california i'm in space bro you
can get any different not any dispensary
but we're we're big in northern
california southern california major
markets what sets you guys apart from
the competition we are all about quality
we're our small batch we focus on the
customer experience and we want to make
sure that the the the patient is getting
a
unique leveled cannabis smoking
experience whether they use it for
medicine or for for for for a little
weed tip i am somewhat of an expert on
me
just look for the most thc
but
that's gonna hook you up i was like stew
smokes huh first first place at the
cannabis cup
northern california so
i'm not we're not you know we're not
messing around i'll help you with the
marketing though uh i'll be like all
right get what is your company called
atrium cultivation atrium cultivation
get your balls licked on this by the way
that laughs i'm sorry
to apologize that was mostly an
off-camera delivery left but the laugh
was about he was saying
don't look for that please
please well everyone does that all the
time they just go for the highest thc
give me the highest one because they
just want to get [ __ ] up and do
nothing and be non-functional i mean i
guess today's video is brought to you by
upstart credit card debt can be very
scary especially when it feels like
you're in this never-ending cycle of
debt upstart can help you make that
final payment so you can get ahead oh
ahead i want to get oh yeah upstart is
the fast and easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan all online
whether you're paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment that's
wonderful upstart knows we're more than
just our credit scores so they're
expanding access to affordable credit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and your current employment
to find you a smarter rate for your loan
that's right and with just a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
to fifty 000
holy moly and you can receive funds as
quick as one business day after
accepting your loan so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
by going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record and don't forget to use
that url so they know that we sent you
guys loan amounts will be determined
based off of your credit your income and
other information that you put on your
application go to upstart.com off the
record what's your most preferred way of
getting a little baked a little high do
you like to smoke do you like to edible
it do you like to [ __ ] inhale it
through your butt just to smoke that's
why i like to do it just a joint or
water water pipe oh on a bog you like
the big rips not like you just do a
small one i like pipes because i did
like joints but then um i'm very
eco-friendly and i don't like to let it
waste does that make sense yeah also i
don't like to waste the weed yeah you
waste a lot of weeds but then the joint
is so cool though because you feel like
jimmy hendrix
yeah and you play guitar and [ __ ]
it's my lifelong dream of wanting to
become like joe camel you know because i
grew up in that era where they were like
oh joe campbell's cool and they're like
he's too cool illegal get rid of them
smoking cigarettes is probably one of
the coolest things that ever you know i
don't know i always look at it as being
i totally agree with you i [ __ ] hate
cigarettes me too i hate cigarettes but
on film it just looks so good that guy
is so good he has a badass
just watching him get lung cancer i'm
like damn yes just like or when they're
like stressed i'm like yo i need to
focus there's nothing cool to dude james
dean with the top down with a cigarette
in his mouth and because the top down is
putting out his cigarette but it looks
cool
it's impossible to light that cigarette
going
on the pch he's like
he's trying to let a match and we know
he's going 100 miles an hour
every single piece of ember is just
sucked out of that [ __ ] day it's
completely put out yeah dude smoking
cigarettes used to be so cool and
everyone's doing those [ __ ] little
cartridge vapes the vapes
they look like cucks when they do it but
it smells so good though it does
it's illegal but i was like oh just make
it legal because i like it when the
whole room smells like strawberry
perfume and [ __ ] i have a question do
they have um so obviously like i'm brown
right so hook is big in the brown
community
is there like any do they make like
particular flavors for the for the asian
community like [ __ ] lychee or
something be serious no because there's
there's for like for the south asian
community there's something called pond
which is like a it's like a people eat
it after dinner but it's like just like
mince and sweet and like weird [ __ ] that
no one ever knows the ingredients and
it's wrapped in a leaf and you kind of
you chew on it sometimes they'll put
chewing tobacco like depending but they
have like sweet versions but like you
can get it as a flavor and like hookah
are now in cartridges in the vapes and
i'm like these [ __ ] are just
going straight for the cultural cultural
jugular yeah i had bubble gum hookah
that's for my people
they got bazooka
yeah big league chew
was it pretty accurate did it really
taste like
money what's your biggest my favorite
was cola cola
i've never got that and it tastes
exactly like it [ __ ] off grape is the
shrimp great people love to hate on
grape by the way no great big league
chew it's the one oh legit i thought you
meant great pooka grape is pretty good
grape grape mint grape mint
mine's coca-cola or cola
and um watermelon watermelon flavor do
you get the whole fruit set up oh yeah
i've seen the setup but it's the flavor
yeah isn't there that one called like
starbury or something there's some off
made up [ __ ]
they're like that's like going to space
yeah shooting star like what the [ __ ] is
this supposed to taste like death
am i going to get incinerated
am i going to go through the atmosphere
and catch on fire
dude i remember when i was in high
school the coolest thing you could do
was like go to the hookah lounge like 18
plus baby yeah but we were 18 but we
would go and be like yeah like i'll get
a hookah bro and we would [ __ ] smoke
on starbursts and [ __ ] you know
starbucks star buzz dude
sometimes if i smoke too much you could
immediately i'm like oh man you feel
sick i'm like i'm gonna get diarrhea
it's coming like really i feel like it's
like it's like you know how people smoke
cigarettes take [ __ ] but it's like that
on steroids because you're like
and then i'm like oh god i'm gonna take
a [ __ ] is it a diuretic in there well
nicotine just irritates your stomach
probably yeah you gotta you gotta have
you get an iffy stomach if you smoke too
and i'm like sweating i'm like i gotta
go
home
you also mentioned spicy food during one
of the breaks oh
i'll have you know that i will kick your
[ __ ] ass at spicy
this is like that is almost like a
racial insult
that guy's not dude this guy's a wife
all right next time i'm here let's go
let me hear some resume you need to
impress me name it bro no but like okay
see number one okay so wait i need to
pick some some like
like okay
at buffalo wild wings what's your go-to
mild bro
are you gonna are you really gonna do
buffalo wild rings i'm asking that's
just the most [ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever had
you bring me the though
he still hasn't answered my question i
don't remember what it's called oh yeah
the hottest hot one
but it's not that good i got a good one
he goes to a thai restaurant and gets
hot i go i get the hottest did you do
that but he says for thai people not for
white people
i say tell your tell the show
your mother's a goat
they look at you because you know what's
funny so my my roommate's wife and he
eats spicy food and so we'll go to like
a thai restaurant and be like
thai spicy that's what we'll say thai
spicy and the waiter whoever it is i
know
we'll ignore me will ignore me
completely and be like see my room be
like
are you sure
[Laughter]
and i'll always burst out laughing and
he's like
yes ma'am we're sure
dude it's so bad i have to have my wife
order spicy ass and i order what she
wants because then they'll give me what
i want because they won't give it to me
because then why did i let's do it let's
go let's go
let's go to the hospital bro yeah just
go let's just go straight there
have you guys ever done one of those
thai spicy too oh yeah
have you guys ever done like the spicy
chip challenge we should do that next
time let's do that let's do the one chip
challenge i've never done it i've never
done it i hope i literally die
i hope that i start sweating like
profusely because i see people do that
and i'm wondering if that's comparable
to like thai spicy or like berries
what is it what is one chip challenge
it's like a ghost pepper it's a ghost
pepper dorito but i forget the company
yeah it's one it's just one chip shaq
did it on tnt you could buy one chip at
a time yes it's sold like
is it like like this so he ate it and he
was like i'm good and then it was like
and he started sweating i don't think
it's devastating okay have you guys ever
tried flashbang or any
the dropper stuff yeah that kind of
stuff yeah so i've had one where i
literally i put it on a plate i took a
toothpick yeah and i dipped it yeah and
this is basically like straight up
pepper spray extract it has no it has no
flavor yeah it has no flavor i know it's
it's just it's not even hot it's a
weapon yeah it's a weapon
yeah and like literally just the pick of
a toothpick and i just and i was like
whoa whoa it takes one gallon of water
to dilute one drop whoa
[ __ ] that's funny so you don't taste it
at all wow did you start like like you
say you'd start sweating but that's why
i always wonder like on hot ones
because i saw a gary vaynerchuk went on
there and like when i eat chicken wings
like i eat everything like cartilage
everything's off it's bone like i'll eat
the bone like like i haven't eaten in 20
years i eat until it's boring and then i
drop it yeah it's like so sometimes i
don't need the cartilage because it's
boring that's just no no let's see for
me that's the best part that [ __ ] looks
like an arcade archaeological [ __ ]
fine when i it looks like a goddamn
t-rex that was just like a baby t-rex
who's the bone soft i'll either crack
the boat and have it eat the merrell
yeah i love it i look like a a coyote
picked up a poodle and then got caught
[Applause]
and ran away
that's good that was very specific yeah
you're there though you can see it you
painted that really well yeah
thank you but i get the sauce off that's
for damn sure sauce is the best part it
licks the soft off sauce is off until
the wing is white again
let's let's do the one chip we have the
sauce here actually we do i mean i think
it's right over there like next to the
user right right now
what do we got are you [ __ ] seeing oh
is that it what is it that looks like a
vial of blood yeah yeah
that's the one like uh let's see is it
expired wait let's see
no we don't have the one anymore i think
that's the one we made the demon try
isn't it i know no that that's that's
the one that's the one i don't think we
tried that one no i flew i threw out the
flashbang because it expired yeah be
really careful of that stuff oh god
smell it first
it's probably oldest yeah i'm like four
years old
it smells like prunes yeah don't don't
even
watch is like tamarind syrup
it smells
it smells like that you're right yeah it
smells sour it does it smells like that
yeah we should throw that away i don't
want that should we try it before we do
it
this guy's in dude
it's like four years old yeah it's old
yeah but what was the main ingredient
just oil i don't know what that actually
is though what is it i don't know what
that is i didn't buy that did we buy it
for a challenge i think um oh you might
want to wash your hands because we had
some like okay clothes we had a lot of
prank hot sauces here and some of them
you put i mean for me i'm not like a
crazy tolerance but you take one drop
and your forehead gushes and your ears
start ringing yeah the ear ringing some
of them you take one and you just the
the day is done yeah
my ears ring with you're a [ __ ]
badass
you're the biggest dick ever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you